I figured we'd do something fun today.
And by fun, I mean the exact same thing
as always, but in a lab coat.
All right, here's the plan. I finally
late last night, I figured out the bug
that was making it so that we couldn't
train anything in the C++ trainer. I'll
show it a little later. It was horrible.
Uh, what we're going to do here is I'm
going to go through, we're going to fix
up the consistency check so I can prove
that the Python trainer and the C++
trainer are exactly the same.
And then we're going to start stripping
out all these like slow things I've done
for testing. I'm going to see how fast
we can get Puffer Lib to learn.
use buffer liib CPP
and if I recall
yeah so this is on CPU in C++
160 something,000 steps per second very
slow by puffer standards, very fast by
everybody else's standards,
and it is trained
almost perfectf.
So, what we're going to do next, uh, a
few things. First,
I'm going to show you the test that I
wrote.
Here's your puffer check.
Yeah. Puffer check.
and then we'll do this on CPU.
It's going to spam us a whole bunch.
And you can see that I had been uh
messing with this. Fix this up. We're
going to have a clean lean test.
this watch off as well. It's bothering
me.
I haven't gotten any heavy lifting in
either. So,
Start by commenting out all these
freaking prints.
You see, I'd been like, this is the
amount of debugging I've been doing. I'd
basically been going through every
single possible tensor, checking every
number to the tenth digit, making sure
there was no difference between CPP and
Python. And like there is going to be
some very small difference at the end of
the day because um the numeric backends
are not guaranteed to be the same, but
from what I've seen, it's pretty damn
close. And uh even when there was a bug,
it was still pretty close. I'll show you
what that bug was in a little bit.
Okay. So,
there's your check passing
with Adam as well, right? I was using
SGD for a bit in order to make that
work. Oh, yeah. We need to do
make sure that everything passes though.
Welcome, son of Liberty. I am a huge fan
of C. What problems do you have with
Python that it is so slow? It is so
ungodly slow. And then the [ __ ] that
people do to make it fast is literally
worse than writing it in C. I can't even
tell you how many times I've seen Python
code that's more complicated than
low-level code that's still slower just
for the sake of PF. It is unbelievably
stupid.
I am sick of this language.
I could be persuaded to do things other
than just C if um if there were actually
adoption for any other like good
language, but realistically I don't
think that there are any other widely
used languages that are good.
Okay, so if I do five of these, the OBS
is going to mismatch. Can I do three? If
I can get three epochs with it being
numerically the same, that' be nice.
Following Mojo at all?
Not really.
There are some good things with that.
And then they just screwed up some other
things. And also, it's like a company
making a language that's just never
going to catch on.
So, I guess it's just two epochs is all
we get. Or maybe even one training step
plus eval.
One training step plus eval is fine for
this test, honestly.
All right. So, yeah, we're going to have
Okay, there no sell anything in here. So
we can just do
we can actually totally simplify this
check.
Yeah. Now
this whole check right here
and then we'll get rid of this a tall
cuz on a knit it should be exactly the
same
not just kind of close
and then let's see we got args
brain optimizer equal atom
back and
policy.
Yeah, that's a good check right there.
Make sure this still runs.
Welcome, Serves.
I guess you don't like Rust because it's
so inconvenient to write in. Yeah,
because it's inconvenient to write in.
And the problem the error class that it
solves is like not that is not a big
error class.
I don't spend my time worrying about
[ __ ] memory safety. All right.
You people shouldn't be allocating so
much damn memory in the first place
or so often at least like program in it.
Allocate your strus. Cool. Use your
strus free all your stuff and program.
Obviously you have to do some
intermediate stuff sometimes but like
it's mostly a C++ thing honestly. It's
just every freaking standard library.
um thing allocating memory under the
hood
was waiting. You didn't stream. I did
the Axene podcast in the morning
yesterday.
That was what I was counting as the
stream. I've had some other stuff to
take care of this week. I'll probably be
streaming more next week.
I've also gotten this whole big thing
done though. Welcome mechanics.
All right.
So we have the test running
that the implementations are identical.
Oh,
are you wearing a lab coat? Yes, I am.
Happy Halloween.
thoughts on Super Maven?
Yeah, Super Maven is uh is the only
usable thing out there.
Honestly, I might just go back to not
using AI in my work, like in my
programming. I don't write that much
Python anymore. I might just get an LSP
and call it a day. Right? The whole
thing was that the LM autocomplete was
useful in the first place because LSP
kind of sucks in Python. Um, but I could
just use a standard LSP and I'd probably
be 70% as good
contact. I've chatted with that guy in
person before.
The requirement though for podcast is
that um it's not like some like highle
[ __ ] Where's AI going in 10 years?
Right?
If it's technical and about actual work,
then that's cool.
let's get rid of the uh the C++ uh the
CPU requirement.
Yeah. See this? I like I moved
everything to the CPU because I thought
maybe the numeric were screwing us up
there and they might still be screwing
us up. But we're going to just do this
first and we're going to see if this is
uh good enough.
If this works,
we'll be able to start actually getting
some real perf out of this. Yeah.
Is it a costume if you're a doctor?
True.
But, you know, I always thought it was
super lame that you get to the AI lab at
MIT or Stanford or whatever and it's
like a bunch of dudes like mostly skinny
dudes in blue jeans with no actual
equipment.
No lab coats, no like fancy
tech in the background, like freaking
laptops, man. Lame.
cursor and wind surf getting accused of
using Chinese lightweight models.
I I don't understand why people think
that like these are good. They're just
bad. I
like stop using them. You're a bad
programmer. Just stop.
Learn to write your freaking code.
Using LLMs for docs these days is
unfortunately kind of required because
people just stopped bothering to write
good docs because they assume that
you're just going to type them into an
LS an LLM anyways.
So that's at least understandable.
And docs includes like example code
because your docs should just have a
bunch of example code.
That's funny.
Are you wait are you aware of toading?
Yeah, I've seen his stuff.
You can build with just the C compiler.
Well, wait. You don't need CMake. I
don't We don't have CMake on Puffer
stuff either.
We just have I mean, we don't use C for
our build script. You very well could, I
guess. Uh, we just have like a simple
bash script
build.sh, right?
What the hell's wrong with this thing?
What am I developing? Ultra high
performance reinforcement learning. It's
all right here on puffer.ai.
Oh, yeah. I wanted to go find the uh the
command, but real quick, did we hit 4K?
No, we're 12 stars off from 4K. Can we
hit this today? That'd be awesome. If
you haven't started the repo, start the
repo. It helps a lot.
Uh, right. We were going to do
stack trace CPP.
I forget the flag name. It's like torch
CPP. Yes. Go CPP stack traces, right?
Spencer's new M. Yeah. Yeah. Spencer's
been doing cool stuff.
Grep app search.
Huh? Is that just like um like AI
retrieval? So you get real code
Just get up. Cool.
Uh, why is this just giving me a psych
vault? This is dumb.
Only got uh two hours for streaming, I
think, today. So, we're going to try to
crank some good results. I want to get
like a full demo of this CPP trainer on
stream today. That'd be good.
What is this
Python threading?
Do I need to rebuild everything? I'm
confused.
Try this and then we'll see if I uh I
can get myself a proper trace.
No idea mechanics. Should be pretty
good.
I want puffer 4 to be 10 million plus
steps per second though.
Beex computer. Do we need to train a
model? Uh, well, for the hundred some
odd thousand steps per second, you need
a potato.
And uh, for what I'm doing with my
normal stuff where I'm getting several
million, I'm on a 4090. We have plenty
of users on other GPUs as well, just a
desktop, like a good desktop for some of
the higher per stuff.
All right. So, what is happening with
um,
why is Python seging?
I hate Python.
Well, I don't know what this
should I focus on learning
reinforcement.
Are you interested in it?
I'm not going to tell you like should
you or should you not study a thing,
right? That's are you interested in the
thing? You're asking about if it's a
good field to get a job in. I'm not the
right person to ask on that.
Just not how I think about things.
Obviously, I've made a job out of it,
but
No, we should be able to get a trace out
of this. What the hell is happening
here?
What is happening with this?
No Python frame. Like what?
I can try the Python one.
Okay. Can I just like
I mean how is this even in threading?
That's like I'm not threading stuff.
They shouldn't be able to seg
torture being weird
without this. Just seg right.
right. So, I don't understand why this
is seagging and I don't understand why I
can't get a trace.
Normally, I should just be able to get a
trace.
Let me see if I can get a debugger. I
don't think so, though. If I can't get a
trace, then I shouldn't be able to get
debugger. But
messaged you a while back on Twitter
chat. chat.
Uh, I will show you what my DMs look
like in case I missed that.
All right, this is what my freaking DMs
look like.
It's like all freaking spam, so I do
miss stuff occasionally. Let me see.
Okay. Uh, I don't see it. So, either
send me something else or tell me the
name that you sent it under, like the
handle.
Oh, on the stream chat. What? I messaged
you a while back on
I don't see any messages from Aditia
today.
Like if you mean you've been around in
general, then yes, I remember in Aditia.
Oh, you dummy. Why is it Why does this
Seg vault instead of um
That's really weird that this egg faults
here instead of giving me an actual
error.
This is CUDA.
camp. Well, why would that seg? That's
weird.
Went through puffer lib. Also watch your
PhD defended thesis. Super cool.
Autonomous driving company working and
playing. Oh, cool. Yeah, there are a
couple driving companies that are uh
apparently using
the main thing we do in that space is
we've got a port of NYU's sim. So, you
know, they built this uh GPU drive sim
and we did a port of it to Puffer. It's
way faster now and they're using it and
a bunch of other folks are using it as
well.
Thank you. Worksman inspiring. Hope to
work for you someday. Thank you. if
you're interested in doing um stuff
generally like all of Puffer is open
source and there are a heck of a lot of
things around here um that we have all
sorts of people working on
currently working myself on the major
major stuff for 40 but
I know if you have planning benchmarks
little test M's in mind things that you
think are like hard to solve but we
think we should be able to solve most of
these M's are just by contributors
And some of them are pretty useful in
research.
We just merged this thing in properly
finally the other day.
Okay, there we go. So there is puffer
squared training 4 million.
4 million steps per second.
Can we run check?
That's so annoying that there's
literally a CUDA backend difference.
All right, let's see how big of a
difference this is.
Oh, that's a really big difference.
Okay, so something I think is probably
broken here. Does this train?
Okay, we'll have to keep an eye on this
then.
So, we'll just do um
Yeah, hang on.
Let's make a very dedicated commit here.
Hello. Welcome.
All right. That's um that's the first
chunk of thing done.
Yeah, convert. We've got uh we got a
prototype of the CPP working. We're
going to do some PF stuff on it right
now. Uh well, right after uh first bench
set of the Okay.
Still got the 200 for eight.
Haven't [clears throat] been doing
enough training lately. The C++
implementation's been bothering me.
We'll see if this gets it to be any
faster.
It should.
There's also probably a redundant
synchronize.
Try this first.
Okay, so the CPP is a bit faster. Uh
it's just that all the speeds globally
are down for whatever reason on the
desktop right now.
And this is not the area where we think
it's going to give us the most speed
benefit either.
That's 3.9
4.4
2080 and then when we do here.
Okay, interesting. It's saying that the
train loop is faster in Python, which
makes no bloody sense at all. Let's
figure that out,
right? Yeah, it's saying that the eval
is faster, but the train is slower.
Uh, we got it to run, Jess. So, we have
some training and it's a little bit
faster than uh Python, but there's still
some things to debug to like figure out
why we're not getting the full expected
speedups.
If we hit the 4K on stream, I'll pull
the I'll I'll hit the first two plate
bench in quite a while
All right. So, it's 3.5 for Python and
then
Now, let me figure out I think there's
something about how I'm doing the uh
stats.
How much is this costing?
this whole thing.
Yeah.
Let me just make sure I didn't screw up
the time zone. I have an important
meeting later.
We're uh finishing up a bunch of client
things for the end of the month.
At 2 p.m.
Cool.
I'm gonna have to go a little bit before
too though because this uh my audio does
not like to work.
I'm probably going to have to take
meetings from my phone which sucks.
Okay. So, there's the 4.3 back. So you
actually lose a lot of PF just in these
like stupid loss calcs.
So I think it's 4.3 is as fast as it
gets. Right.
Okay, there's our four mil whatever
left.
Should be able to get this over 5 mil
though if I remember.
Auto complete gives you such stupid
stuff sometimes. Like much easier here.
Making progress.
long. And really,
there's no way to divide
It's like, hey, I don't know how to
divide by a float. Like the hell?
Invalid cast from type C10. Okay.
All right. What's wrong with this?
Like
That's incredibly stupid that you have
to do it with uh
C++ is just dog [ __ ] like
Now, let's see how much overhead we're
los like how much perf we're losing.
How much perf we losing to all of this
logging in general.
4.4 44.5 then
no meaningful perf loss from That's as
we expected.
Local AI dev learns to manage types. I
know how to manage types. Ask the
[ __ ] C++ devs if they know how to
manage types.
Thing is like C++ is like, you know,
that kid in school that would just raise
his hand to ask clever sounding
questions that if you thought about for
more than two seconds were completely
[ __ ] stupid.
>> Yeah.
I know cuz I used to be that little
[ __ ]
But if you just look at this, it's
completely stupid. Like what? Why did we
have to reinvent what the [ __ ] a cast
is?
Million ways to do everything. They're
all dog [ __ ]
Okay. Well, we got the implementation up
to something reasonable. Um, there
should be an equivalent
you don't even get max you don't even
get kernel selection in
How the hell can there not be a way to
do this?
So brain dead, man.
This is like so brain damaged.
I don't understand how the hell you have
so many engineers working on stuff and
you get something like this.
Like why the [ __ ] would this be
dependent on this?
I didn't know there's such thing like
online RL and offline RL. Well, the
article I wrote says that there isn't a
thing as offline RL. Offline RL is
really supervised learning.
But online RL, the idea is you're
learning by interacting with the
environment,
right? It's like you're learning by
trial and error plus algorithm.
I'm trying to figure out though. Hang
on. There's still something weird with
this, isn't there? Because
So 50/50, right?
So each forward and back train and uh
and eval
are running at about um 7 million steps
each.
And then here
this is running at like five and this is
running way h way faster. Sure.
Isn't it a problem that an algorithm
doesn't know what's important? That's
what RL does
No, see we still have
It's like very clearcut here.
Oh, hang on. Let me go check one thing.
Yeah. So this is totally the case then,
right? That the Python somehow the
Python train loop is faster. We have to
figure out what's different between
these two.
Never all copper
uh simulation is still used extensively
and our simulations run really fast.
Like we can literally train on thousands
of years worth of simulated data on one
server.
You can't cover all possible cases
directly in the real world either.
There's some amount of robustness in
generality. One second, guys.
All right,
packages.
We're having a little fun here on
Halloween with Perf Optimization.
Uh well
fun meaning doing the exact same thing
as normal. No lab coat but
yeah welcome Jess. Yeah. How you been
here? Uh
I mean pretty much it's just a matter of
like why.
So it's 20% compute and 70% compute.
Like the split is totally
different, right?
now see this has frequency set to one
already.
This thing actually has
Yeah. the full uptime covered.
Oh, but wait, this doesn't call
synchronize.
So, yeah, this might not be timing
correctly. Let's try this.
Uh, no, this is timing correctly, it
seems.
Oh, but this one might not be timing
correctly.
Okay, this one is timing correctly and
it actually gets even slower.
So, at least now we're seeing the PF.
But, uh, this one is still training
faster, I believe,
right? because this is like
half the time
or hang on.
Is that right?
No.
This is just saying the end is
No. This is just saying the end is running slower. Okay. I think it's fine.
running slower. Okay. I think it's fine.
Yeah, I think it's fine overall.
Oh yeah. And we're going to be able to
do B float as well, which will be
better.
No faster.
That is a little odd. know
for this thing not to really be any
faster.
Let me just make sure something screw is
not going on. So if I'm right, this
should not train, right?
Yeah. So, this doesn't train. That's
correct.
I want to see what they're doing with
AMP now.
Yeah, this is doing exactly what I would
expect.
Let's just get the whole thing to do
this first and then we'll see.
Okay, 7 million.
Except
we're not actually training correctly.
Yeah, we don't need to have these two
policies, I don't think.
and get another bench set in. We're
going to get AM at least.
I'll be good.
Okay. So, there's the scoping thing.
Cool.
Yeah, this is like implicit name space,
right?
Okay. It's kind of cool that you can do
this,
but um
it's a heck of a lot easier if we just
do
it this way.
Oh, I forgot the include, didn't I?
Yeah, dummy.
Hang on. I just forgot the include.
I assume you mean 1.2.x. I don't. You
stupid.
What are your honest thought about
Dreamer v3?
Uh, it's like the most beautifully
written paper ever and it's like
completely misleading. It's like
probably the most misleading paper I've
read. Yeah, that [ __ ] does not remotely
work anywhere near as well as there's
written on paper. I've spent a ton of
ton of time on it. Multiple of the best
RL researchers I know have spent a ton
of time on it. That thing is a piece of
[ __ ] And model based RL in general
maybe, but that paper is the best
evidence for it. And that paper is
garbage.
So,
I've wasted enough time [ __ ] with
modelbased RL.
Um, there is only like half a reason to
think it should work and
I'm not wasting any more time with it
until there's like substantial reason
to.
Jess, there's really like nothing I can
ask other than like, hey, why does
nothing [ __ ] remotely work as cleanly
as described in the paper? Why is all of
the reasoning given for everything
completely backwards and wrong? and like
Yeah.
No, puffer lib is model free. Well, I
mean puffer lib is more than just the
training algorithm, right? But the
algorithm we use is model free.
Model based in this sense means um that
you are directly constructing a
predictive model of the future. The
puffer lib is training an agent without
explicitly constructing a predictive
model of the future.
But that's like pretty far off of the
type of stuff I'm doing here. Dreamer is
the thing that's superficially kind of
close and that just doesn't work.
How does it know what to do? I mean,
read the tutorials, right? You don't
need a predict like you don't need an
explicit planning model in order for
these algorithms to work. And often
times that explicit planning model is
just super slow.
they very well it's actually guaranteed
that implicitly they are learning some
sort of world model
um
whether it's going to be
implicitly to some extent yes it's just
a matter of There he is.
Dude, why do they implement [ __ ] like
not at the C++ layer?
Okay, so pietorrch is just kind of bad.
Um,
that's annoying.
Yeah, that's fad.
Well, I can still do it. I just can't
use um
what and for What do you see minus
minus? It's a joke. It's C++. But I hate
C++. So I call it C minus minus
We can try this.
That's kind of obnoxious though that
they just never implemented it.
Is there actually a language called C
minus minus?
Yeah, that's niche enough that I'm going
to use keep using the joke anyways.
No, Son of Liberty. It really wouldn't
be because you're not using a lot of the
fancy C++ stuff anyways for the uh the
low-level ops. You could very, and look,
technically CUDA is uh CPP, but like the
actual kernels themselves really aren't.
Um, you could very very easily have like
a seed like interface that just gives
you direct access to optimized kernels,
you know, a simple autograd and a lot of
the stuff that you actually want out of
torch when you're doing this type of dev
and they just didn't. It's like a
hundred times more bloated than it needs
to. Maybe not 100 times, but it's at
least 20 times more bloated than it
needs to be.
Do you find?
Well, I'm not using it, so no.
I'm currently using Super Maven, which
cursor
uh bought and is killing next month. So,
I'm probably going to go back to just
not using any AI complete. I'm probably
just going to get an LSP finally
and be done.
Jess, you come build it with me.
that's going to That would be
It'd be a pain in the ass.
It would definitely be a pain in the
ass.
Because pietorch is a really big
project. So yeah, people have done it,
but nobody's actually like put in the
work to make it a mature library, right?
I mean, realistically, I suppose you
don't even need that many things, but
like it's difficult because it's very
difficult for projects like this to grow
because uh nobody knows how the [ __ ] to
program anymore. So like everybody just
wants their shitty Python interface to
everything
and they like expect a bunch of dumb
things to be there that you don't
actually need.
I don't know. Maybe I'm just getting old
and grumpy, but
Last bench set. We're going to make this
run at least and then I got to get ready
for my
So Jess, the thing to do would not be to
go implement all of torch to start. The
first thing you do is go see like if you
can just get custom fused kernels for
our networks.
It'd be a lot more for there.
Well,
it runs
and it's stable,
but it's half the speed because um
the LSTM does not have good
kernels.
Okay.
We'll keep this though because that's
the next problem to solve.
I will be streaming a lot early next
week.
We're really going to try to hammer out
the Perf optimizations. We're getting
close. We basically need to have either
a BF16 kernel or an alternative cell
architecture.
Ideally, an alternative cell
Think I'm going to play around with
minstm and GRU.
If you enjoy the content here, this is
all free stuff. It's all at puffer.ai.
If you want to help me out for free,
absolutely free, start the repository.
We are 10 stars off of 4,000. So feed
the puffer a star. It helps a lot. If
you want to get involved with
development, most of which does not look
like this horrible low-level
optimization. Most of it's like chill
low-level gamedev that actually benefits
science.
Discord's here. Docs are here.
And if you want more content,
follow on X. I post a whole bunch of
stuff. It's all technical
and uh a lot of long form content as
well. It's not just like two sentence
bits.
Occasional fitness thing, but mostly
just research.